I live in LA thank you but I'm from a
town called Normal Illinois no normal is
a very suspicious name for a town keep
passion by Normal Illinois nothing weird
going on here no everything's normal and
normal Illinois
like if you named your town normal you
all have tails and I can say that I'm
from normal and I have a tail I just had
the decency to tuck it into my sports
bra every day I got a half compliment
from a man at my local bar
it was raining I walked in from across
the bar he's like hey hey you know you
kind of look like Charlize Theron well
oh well like yeah I just re-watched
monster just like her
[Music]
I don't know if this has happened to you
guys but I was sitting on my couch and a
tooth dropped out of my mouth just like
it's disgusting
out of my mouth onto my lap I just
thought like as you get older like your
back would ache but like stuff just
falls off what happens and it sucks
because I used to get paid to lose my
teeth some people are smart inhere good
lose the tooth and I put it under my
pillow and then my mom will come by at
night and she'd leave a check for a
dollar under there that's when I
suspected we were poor I knew we were
poor when the next morning she woke me
up and she's like hey honey do you mind
not cashing that check till Friday but
it broke tooth fairy
I don't know if you know these people
there's a lot of them in LA they put
stickers on the back window of their car
and it's their entire family it's like a
stick figure of their entire family it's
like a dad and a mom and three kids and
a dog I can't stand those people
there's bragging to all the single
people out there with one sticker that
says just me and when it rains it looks
like they're crying
like I would give any amount of money to
see the moment when that couple realizes
that their marriage is no longer gonna
happen it's not working they walk out to
the driveway their heads down and just
slowly peel off that dad sticker slap it
on an uber go into his brother's futon
clear my bank account for that did you
guys ever stop and think man Casper the
Friendly Ghost is a dead child it's just
odd anyways I went to my sister's
wedding my sister had a destination
wedding and the destination was a
bowling alley in Wisconsin I was the
only person to get the vegetarian plate
at the entire wedding and they bring me
over Wisconsin's finest vegetarian but I
just didn't want to know how like a
bowling alley prepared trout so they
bring me over this plate a vegetarian
plate and I swear to god it was just a
plate full of loose corn she's like I
think they took a can of corn and just
dumped it on a plate that's what they
did
I can't even digest this you know
I don't like going to weddings because I
don't like when couples write their own
vows and they're like really proud of it
even though it's bad and it all sounds
the same every wedding it's the same
vows you are my best friend I wrote that
you are my partner in crime you are my
sister's ex-boyfriend
sorry SUSE guys thank you so much
[Applause]